and i just lobbed this stone grenade
anyway
stunned them and we went down to the
bottom
and a vehicle
reversed in a tank a warrior reversed in
the back doors opened and we all piled
in the back
and that was it the vehicle just stayed
there i'm chugging on the commander's
leg we need to go now and it turned out
the driver had been hit in the head
[Music]
um so craig obviously we've met a couple
of times over the last few years but for
anyone that's watching or listening for
the first time would you mind
introducing yourself who you are yeah
i'm craig harrison um i held the
longest sniper kill on record
in afghan in 2010
and um in the army for 20 20 23 years
just under 23 years and um
yeah so that's that's my story well
let's get straight into it um can you
tell me a little bit about your
childhood and how you grew up
yeah basically um i had a good childhood
you know and we went on a horse riding
holiday
when i was a kid
and
my mum said join a horse
so yeah she got us a horse and
i loved it and that's all i did as a
child is do pets horses do my mum's dogs
and stuff like that looking after
animals yeah yeah yeah and my granddad
always said to me when he when he was
alive um
you know
what are you gonna do what you're gonna
do and he said get a trade he was xraf
my mum was xref as well and
i wanted to become a farrier and that's
why i joined the army and i'll join the
household cavalry to
to get a trade so how did that progress
into where you ended up um basically
you think right like i said i was a
showered child
so now i'm in the army i'm in the center
of london i get paid i'm a weekend
[ __ ] millionaire right you know what
i mean i'm not what the [ __ ] country boy
in the middle of the city and i got led
astray by the older sort of generation
and uh doing fights getting drunk and
stuff like that i've never been drunk
before
oh god and it's the first time i was in
the army i went out to a nightclub got
absolutely shit-faced
ended up in a fight and i thought [ __ ]
you know
i felt
i don't know i just felt is this wrong
is this right this is what the army is
all about sort of thing but they're nice
to horse guards go down to do the
parades and all that with my face all
right
i broke a nose split lip split eye and
then the regiment goes enough's enough
so it took me out the london scene and
put me into windsor the green side and
at the point my regiment had the highest
able rate in the british army wow
because lads were just not coping
thinking what the [ __ ] is this what the
army is all about so obviously the
what you're known for is the sniping
yeah so how how does that come about do
people notice you and say
they think you'll be good at it or is it
something you have to be interested in
and apply for like what's the solution
yeah you have to apply for it when you
go on tour and you you halfway through
that tour
um the sergeant major will come and go
what do you want to do right when you
get back to england what do you want to
do because you need to do career courses
to progress and i said i want to be a
sniper
they ignored me
came back a couple of weeks later what
you want to do wouldn't be a sniper
okay ignored me again
and then i never come off that tour and
i never achieved my sniper in and then i
went tall again and he said what do you
want to do i want to be a sniper a
badger badger and eventually they gave
me the opportunity to become a sniper so
i went down to um
uh per bright down in
in surrey and to start my sniper course
now i tipped up there no pre-course so i
haven't got a [ __ ] clue what's going
on
i didn't have a rifle i didn't have a
giddy suit and all these paras tipped up
all the guards tipped up with all their
kit laid out and i just stood there
going [ __ ] out my debt fear and got a
[ __ ] clue so were you meant to have
been given that stuff before your right
well yeah you meant to have a pre-course
right so you got there with an
understanding of what to do right you
know so whose fault was that that didn't
happen my regiments right so they just
sent you off set me off yeah probably to
keep my mouth shut so he's gonna come
back in a few days it's gonna wear thin
oh yeah you know i got lent a rifle off
the coast stream guards i was like
never fired a sniper rifle before i was
going [ __ ] hell yeah
treasured it and then every weekend i
had off on that course the course was
about nine weeks long and every weekend
i had off i went home and my wife never
saw me tanya because i was just building
my ghillie suit building kitty trousers
making my life better in the field
becoming a sniper you know make my life
more comfortable by coming up with ideas
going i'm going to build this this
weekend and i just flourished and
flourished and flourished and i became
oh i got top student 30 started the
course
um
top of my head i can't remember i think
six past six or four on top of my head
but i came top student out of all of
them the first household cavalry now
they took the piss out of me called me a
donkey walloper hall shagger you know
you're [ __ ] outside cavalry they go
every time you walk past them you know
but
so what i became top student so what
does it take to be a good sniper at a
base level
i remember
being in
iraq and i remember we went to a place
called alamada in iraq and we had to
fight to get this
city
it was horrendous fighting and i wasn't
a sniper then
and
we took over this football stadium
massive football stadium and um the
irish the royal irish were there
and i remember going for a walk just to
clear my head a bit i went in this
football stadium i was just walking
around you know the 400 meter track
and i looked up and i could see snipers
pinpointed around the top on the high on
the high ground around the uh stadium so
i went up and spoke to one do you know
he didn't look at me
he didn't look at me once he was stern
looking for the scope everything and i
thought yeah that's that's what it's
about that's what i want to be focused
yeah focused discipline committed to the
job
you know and
wouldn't be afraid to squeeze that
trigger to take a target out
and that's the most important thing of
being a sniper people think being a
sniper you go out and kill someone
it's not that
it's to gather information on the
battlefield and then relay it back and
then you stay there for long as possible
give that information and they will tell
you to take that shot or not if the
target is feasible or it is a high
profile target and that's what sniper is
all about you know and
they break you down in the sniper score
they break your [ __ ] they break you
with fitness running around you know how
to walk anywhere you got to run away
you've got every ghillie suit on all the
time you're sweating your tits off
you're knackered you're tired and
yeah they break you down and then they
build you back up with a different
discipline so when you get back to the
regiment you're you're a different
soldier total different soldier you're
an a1 soldier so you get badged as a
sniper and then you're
sent out for your first tour as a sniper
yep
do you remember the feelings that
accompanied that
yeah i was the only sniper in the in my
squadron i was only set up in the
regiment
god so when you're talking about the
fact that your job is reconnaissance and
providing information that must have
been a huge responsibility yeah yeah we
my um first going out as a role as a
sniper was in iraq when we evaded a vac
there was no pressure on me at the time
because we're all together and we're all
doing the same thing
but when you get called up saying yeah
we need a sniper here
you know and i'm not
looking around going
that's [ __ ] me
you know you grab your rifle and you go
up and i remember
uh being in the desert
uh in a place called the maisan desert
and it was vast this desert it's [ __ ]
hot and it's horrible
and um we're in a mog like a mobile
operational group okay
and it moves around the desert and where
there's an op going on they can provide
men to it and it saves us going all the
way back to basra it's coming all the
way forward again right so we'd stay
there
and um
should we just move around this desert
and you could be 100 miles from any
location
and every time we stopped we used to get
mortared and we couldn't figure out what
was going on so we'd move to another
location mortars would come in
and they were aiming for the thing that
the fuel um truck we call an oshkosh but
it's a fuel truck that was fueling all
our wagons right and they were aiming
for that to a blur and if they hit that
i wiped a knee or the mug out because it
would have been just a horrendous
explosion
and we noticed every time we stopped
there was a motorbike going by
and um he was [ __ ] us
and [ __ ] you yeah but you can't call
him dickers anymore because it's uh just
more alarming against him okay she had
to call him scouts right yeah so he was
scouting he was scouting us dick in us
yeah he'll stick it and he was [ __ ]
us and um he would go off next location
mortared more moored
so um i got called up to the ops room
and they said yeah you need to take this
guy out and he's about six
675 yards away and i remember laying on
his bank
the
mog moved off
left me there
and
as the motorbike came into view
um i took the shot
now in the heat you have to only if you
ever see it on films when you see
somebody in the desert walking towards
you they look higher that's because of
the heat shimmer um so i had to
shoot quite high on the target because
he looked quite tall on his motorbike
and um
yeah i hit it i hit he wobbled and fell
off the bike now i thought i hit the
bike
but i i hit the guy here
because
i went up to the body afterwards to
clarify
you know the information to try and get
stuff off him like
maps and stuff like that and i remember
the throttle the bike was stuck in the
sand and he was revving its tits off he
had an ak-47 strapped to the bike he had
a radio called icon
um chatter on it so the taliban were
talking to all like i were talking to
him
asking where he was because i had an
interpreter with me and um he was on the
floor and he passed away and was it
quite an odd feeling it was yeah i i
said to this day now i felt [ __ ] i've
killed someone
i've killed someone i've shot someone
and i felt like i was going to get a tap
on the shoulder at any minute and go can
we have quite a word with you mate right
why did you [ __ ] kill this guy right
going to prison now but it wasn't like
that it was tap on the shoulder going
[ __ ] a good job mate [ __ ] good job
and it took me a good week
to
get my mind in gear thinking that's my
[ __ ] job that's the job of a sniper
you know and i guess that's what you'd
been
training up to up to that point but
yeah again for someone like me i i can't
think about how it because i haven't
done the training i haven't got the
mindset but i can't think about how much
it felt it must feel like a very odd
thing
um it felt like i was hungry my stomach
was turning right
yeah butterflies yeah you're bad
butterflies and i just remember sitting
on my camp cop because every time we
stopped we had put instead of sleeping
on the floor we had hammocks and cam
cots i used to sit on the end of my
camcorder [ __ ] it now
kill someone you know i kept it to
myself
i didn't let to affect you know i um
put in a box put in my brain you know
but it would always stay open now and
again and i'd think [ __ ] i've killed
someone i killed someone was it like a
feeling of if you don't mind me asking
was it like a feeling of guilt or more
just strange strange strange yeah
strange you know because you're in the
army yeah you expect to do something in
that role at some point in your army
career and presumably after you'd seen
him and he was armed you knew that he'd
do the same thing back the other way
and don't forget he was trying to motor
us
you know he's trying to motor us and i
engaged the target
and my optics were quite powerful other
than naked eyes so i could see
you know what he was like and what what
he had on him so yeah and he had maps on
him as well so matt intel we got off it
you know the map of the mesan desert and
he had pinpoints from where we were all
the time so oh wow see he had been
and then after that you know after the
first one which obviously would have had
a big impact did it get easier or did it
was it a gradual
the feeling of
oddness after each kind of what do you
say kill
yeah kill kill yeah does it start to
feel more normalized or does it take a
while before that it starts getting
normal yeah because you believe your
role is a sniper you know like i said
before first roll information gather
that information second role would be to
neutralize destroy or suppress that
target oh yeah you know and um it
becomes more
not like gun happy where you just start
blatant away everywhere but you become
it matures you it does mature you and
you think [ __ ] oh yeah because you
can go to anyone who's in the army done
22 years because you ever shot your
rifle in anger and they've said no i've
done 22 years in the army you know or
you can go to somebody said you see
conflict oh yeah i did yeah i've shot my
rifle as well you know it's 50 50 who
you approach you know and yeah i'm one
of them you've actually shot my rifle
you know one of the things that we did a
video before and the thing that people
find fascinating was the the the
relationship because snipers as a as a
pair aren't they yes that was something
that i think a lot of people hadn't
realized before we made a piece before
like i think a lot of people think of a
sniper as a solo operative of their own
can you explain a little bit how that
relationship works to us there's
in a platoon
or in a section you have 16 guys and
then 16 guys are all snipers
so you work as a pair so each of them 16
guys will be paired off for somebody
else and an officer who's in charge of
you would always stay behind in the ops
room and coordinate the snipers on the
ground there's no such thing as long
wolf anymore you know you just can't go
out on your on your own you know even sf
don't got on their own they're always
going force
you know and so there is a limit so for
me being a sniper and people more
interested in it more people want to do
at the end of the tour what you want to
do become a sniper you know and they
they got the courses and it was up to me
to give them the pre-course then right
so when they went on the course they
weren't going on blind so yeah like you
have yeah absolutely like i did yeah and
um
it's it's funny actually my number two i
did quite a few tours with and
we're both the same so the number one is
usually the better shooter and number
two is usually better at doing all the
calculations the biomaterial pressure
the altitude the distance the
calculations on your scope but me and my
friend i don't want to say his name like
but
we were we were good as a pair and we
took it in turns and i'll be a number
one and he'll be at number two you know
and it's funny enough coming here today
um i bumped into him in the service
station did you really yeah well
completely out of the blue i broke down
i broke down uh
totally
totally [ __ ] up totally [ __ ] up
gives me goosebumps you know totally
what just on your way to to come here he
stopped off and yeah he was there
funnily enough we stopped at a petrol
station and my wife goes um
i don't want to stop here i said okay
then i'll go somewhere else so we went
to the service station and she goes this
is better went there and i was waiting
for her because she went to go and spend
a penny her waiting for her and um as
she came out i heard craig averson well
well well i looked it was my friend i
did so many tours with and i was always
in contact with him always in contact
with him but this last year i've had my
own issues
so i've segregated myself from certain
certain things and um
yeah wow wow and i broke down he's
yeah he's he's um suffers really bad
suffers really bad and um he gets
charged discharged at the army this year
wow yeah
god that's
it's just fake isn't it yeah yeah it was
fake
okay so the the the guy that you were
sort of partnered with that you toured
with like um you know you say that one
of you is usually better at taking the
shot and one's better the calculations
did you have a preference for either one
not really
yeah it gives you a breather beyond the
scope as well you know because you're
always on that scope and you get like
you get a lot you get tired more easily
looking beyond the scope and the spotter
will have a spot in scope now in that
spot and scope the graph the graphical
on that spotting scope is exactly the
same in your sniper scope so when he
looks at some ink and he will go yeah
it's three or more because you've got
little dots in here and they're called
mill dots you go yes three male dots to
the left so you can get your rifle on it
and you can go oh yeah there he is
you know so you can talk you on to it if
you've gotta have that relationship and
me and him had that click you know and
then we went on
and progressed in sniper in so we did
our section commanders together and then
we did our platoon commanders together
and then we did advanced sniper in
together so i couldn't go any more
higher in the sniper world
you know and nor could uh my number two
it must be quite a bundy farm yeah it
really was yeah yeah yeah he's got to
wipe your ass yes you mentioned that
once
just because obviously someone watching
for the first time might go what does he
mean by that yeah yeah you're what
you're looking at you can't move you're
in a location you're on your belly and
you can't move so you just get a little
tupperware tub you roll over and go for
a poo he wipes your ass with a wet wipe
puts in the container puts in his
backpack because your idea is being a
sniper is to leave no ground sign at all
you know because a good tracker is worth
his you know weight in gold will look at
that poo and go yeah he's hydrated he's
eating well his morale is quite high you
know this is the guy we need to watch
out for you know you take it with you
and you you're a ghost you're a ghost on
the battlefield amazing yeah and
yeah i mean stuff like that the ghost on
the battlefield when you say that it's
kind of like i think that's what the
romantic image sounds so cool you know
if i'm being honest to people who
haven't been through that kind of thing
you think of that and it just sounds so
amazing to be to be able to have that
level of skills
and what would you say was like what
what's an average length or in fact
what's an extended length that you might
stay still on the scope for now a sniper
is sustainable on the ground for 48
hours
for a max length for 72 hours would be
the max that's normally 4.72 i hours
looking through the scope yeah but i've
been behind the scope for a week
yeah
in afghan and a place called pandas
ridge and i was on my own i was on my
own then my my number two wasn't with me
so how does sleep work oh you cut that
through the day
you know so i'd rest my um
forehead on the scope and i'd cat nap
for about
i don't know 15 minutes and then i'd
wake up and i'd stay awake for another
four or five hours to not get nap again
and
i mean you must stand up from that at
the end of the period of time and your
body must feel like as stiff as a board
yeah you do yeah because you're not
using your joints what i used to do is
take a trough between my legs so i could
piss and piss myself
and then it would go between the trough
and it just trickled up behind me so and
the your rations that you have you have
things uh we call them dog biscuits
they're like brown biscuits and the
ration packs itself is hard in calories
but it's also designed to um constipate
you
yeah so you you're not [ __ ] all the
time but you you pissed concentric water
but in the heat anyway like a raccoon
afghan you don't get hungry but you know
you find out anyone's listening to this
you find when you go on holiday and you
go to a hot country you don't get hungry
you know but you know well how do you
cope with this like because what you're
saying about going to the to a hot
country i can
relate to that you don't get hungry but
then i'm walking around did a vest and
some shots you're in this full like how
do you not absolutely overheat
um we had special cam nets for the
vehicles and there were israeli cabinets
now one if you tip them the other way
they keep the heat in and they keep the
cold air out for the winter flip from
the other way and they keep the cold air
in and they reflect the heat and they
work and they work yeah unless you're so
tired and you flip it the other way and
you wonder why you're sweating your tits
off
and you realize you've got the cabinet
the wrong way around right
i guess you'd realize that yeah yeah
yeah and then say when you're in that
position for uh say a week you know for
you you were talking about that fact
that when you had somebody
looking at your location when you're in
the mog uh and reporting it back you
realized that somebody was watching you
yeah is it the same the other way around
like if you've been in a period an
extended period of time in one position
do the people that you're observing
start to realize that someone's there or
is it just the fact that you're just
feeding back information and they never
really get a sense of it
um they know you're there they can't
cut they can't see you
and they look for that one shot so that
one shot they disperse they hate that
one shot
so i used to do is tell my support to
open up with the gpg machine gun
and to disguise my one shot ah okay so
you that that creates a load of noise
chaos
one shot slips through that's what it's
meant to do
yeah otherwise you don't hit your target
it's all about
thinking what's what on the battlefield
you know so you had quite a lot of you
know
uh influence over how everyone was
working then i guess didn't you if you
could command and direct people to do
different things what do you think the
naked eyeball
to um at times um 50 fifty skit scope
about magnification on it you know you
you could i could look at you at a
thousand yards and you're like this to
me
you know or a person with a naked
eyeball looking that far would be going
ah has he got
got
a
gun
i'll look at it he goes yeah he has got
a gun
you know so
and when you talk there about the
obviously the 250 meters that makes me
think immediately of the thing that
you're very famous for which is holding
the world record yeah the longest shot
do you mind talking us through no not at
all not at all it was um
now i had um 12 guys at this point um
because some of them have been injured
and how many how many did it start with
60 um 16 right see four of them had yeah
come off the ball yeah even my officer
um so i was doing an officer's job as
well as a sergeant's job and it's you
know when i was
i had loads of things on my mind you
know because an officer has to do a lot
of stuff as well behind the scenes
well anyway this hop was going on
and
it was in a place called talijan
and this village was well renowned for
taliban well-renowned
and
the british army were mixing with the
afghan army to teach him soldiering
skills
and i remember being on the high grounds
because the afghan army wouldn't move
without support so as soon as they saw
vehicles on the high ground it sort of
gave them that fluffy feeling that they
could walk into a village full of for
the taliban because you're looking over
the top yeah for sure and you could see
them and for my position i could see
everything keying up
and um
the patrol was walking towards the the
village itself and i could see all the
taliban queuing up for the attack i had
icon with me same again the interpreter
and i'm going what they're saying he's
relaying to me yeah they can see the
patrol coming the weight's going to get
to the kill zone now the kill zone would
be a box or a field or anything where
there's no cover there's nowhere to run
or anything like that and they'll just
open up and cause as much devastation as
possible to that patrol
and
i saw glimmer
um i thought what the [ __ ] that in the
distance so i've got my scope now
everything every everybody thinks when i
did my shot i was laying down i wasn't
all stood up
oh holding yeah i was yeah yeah i was
letting it go to the compound wall and i
was pushing forward in my um
arm to hold the bipod because the walls
are made out of um cow [ __ ] mud and
straw so every time i fired my weapon a
big chunk of war would fall down from
the shock wave so i was holding my bipod
with my hand and which is a bipod would
be the um that holds the rifle up right
so you're supporting that one i'm
supporting that with my hands
because the wall was just crumbling away
you know and i saw glimmer in the
distance
so i looked for my scope and i could
just make out um a guy with a radio
talking so what i did i fired one shot
didn't get nowhere [ __ ] near him you
know i could see it fall so i fired
another shot
fell and i thought [ __ ] how far is he so
i got my laser binoculars out and
lasered it and it just came out lines so
it's beyond and how far did they go the
laser how far would that have read from
easy fifteen hundred eighteen eighteen
hundred yards
laser two you know and i thought i'm out
here so i put my them down like and i
said what i'm gonna do i'm gonna bracket
so i put my scope on medium
magnification so i got a bigger wider
picture of the battlefield
and um i fired one shot then i fired
another then i looked up fired another
no i caught it lobbing in i was lobbing
in the rounds and my ninth shot hit the
compound wall
and i could see the splash of this
compound wall
and the icon went quiet and i thought
then it spoke up and i said what's he
saying and he's saying oh that he can't
direct the taliban onto the patrol
because he's getting shot at from
somewhere and that person was me
you know that one shot
so i left it there went back to my other
job what i was doing and i engaged
multiple multiple targets in this
village so at this point your group are
under a heavy attack yeah yeah so
they're they're all attacking and
basically the guy with the walkie-talkie
was the one that was telling them what
orchestrating that right
and it's quite hard as a sniper to keep
your mind straight
because you
you're watching people
get injured you're watching people die
on the battlefield
and you've got to keep your composure
and not not snatch that trigger not get
[ __ ] angry you meant to stay calm
keep your breath calm keep your heart
rate down that's what it's all about and
keep in your mind and that's all your
all your training comes together to do
that you know and i always engage
multiple targets now
my spotter
was my driver
and i quickly talked him through the
spotting scope and he tapped me on the
shoulder he goes to somebody over there
and i looked over and i could see
somebody in the far distance about 600
yards away and i thought he was a marker
and i thought we were going to get
flanked in a minute they know because i
fired nine shots and you only meant to
fight three three to one shot and then
move position right got you you know
before they find your location you've
done triple the amount oh yeah yeah
massively
and um i
i turned around
killed him
um put him down and
it turned out not to be a marker what he
had done he had knocked the um
head off the oil well i'm sorry a water
pump and it flooded all the irrigation
ditch so where the fight was happening
in the kill zone would just get like a
quagmire right now because it was all
filling it with water so i thought to
myself what do i do what do i do what do
i do because i'm doing a sergeant job
officer's job i got a think on the hoof
now i've got really think so i said i'll
take my vehicles down i'll stay on the
high ground and i sent four
three vehicles down to act as a buffer
between the patrol
and the village so like a barricade so
they can get them injured out and
they're dead out are they still under
fire at this yeah they are yeah and my
lads are opening up on there and i'm
still engaging targets
now
it went all quiet
you know and when i did my nine shots i
was about eleven o'clock in the morning
this is now about two o'clock in the
afternoon right still fighting now a
normal engagement they do a thing called
shoot and scoot
last for seconds you know and they [ __ ]
off
and they open up again somewhere else
and they [ __ ] off you know shoots good
tactics and the engagement you think in
your head it's lasted for ages you know
but it's only lasted for five to ten
minutes
this lasted until two o'clock and it
went all quiet and i thought
right so i got on the radio and i said
to my lads come back they're betrothed
now in safe ground
you know they're they're tending so
they're injured and they're dead
um i can't see the taliban anymore
so i told my vehicles to extract back
and as i looked at my vehicles coming
back from my scope
and i thought where's that coming from
and i could see splash marks in the
water where my vehicles and all the lads
were on the ground you know taking cover
and i thought where the [ __ ] that
coming from so i checked all my firing
points and i couldn't find any anything
the only thing i didn't check is in the
distance so i looked up and i could see
two taliban behind a machine gun called
a pkm machine gun belt fed russian
machine gun and it was just hoovering
down rounds onto my lads so i thought
[ __ ] so i looked at my lads one got hit
and i thought right i've got to think
think think think keep calm heart rate
brain focus
and i fired my first shot and don't
forget i hit the compound wall so i know
roughly why i'm shooting on the scope
now is that where they were the same
place exactly the same place here they
were laying down
and the first shot hit the side of the
compound wall and i thought so i fired
my second shot
and as the guy one guy stood up i hit
him yeah i hit him here
and he fell backwards
and um
the machine couldn't stop firing
so then i fired my third shot
and as i fired my third shot i moved my
right foot across and fired my fourth
shot now the bullet of flight time was
six seconds
so so lift my rifle to got there i was
counting into six seconds before it hit
the target
now i've got my third shot my fourth
shot three seconds behind each other a
third one missed fourth one hit the guy
and it hit him hit him in the side and
the only reason why hit him is because
you're meant to get that weapon
stop it going back into enemy hands and
the weapon is gone and it was just these
taliban were left
dead and
an apache helicopter came up next to me
before i moved to go and see the dead
guys
and the pilot was really low and he
gpsed it at
2475 meters just over a mile and a half
away and what's the official range of
your rifle 1500 yards
yeah how do you feel when you heard that
i didn't know at the time
you know because
i didn't i didn't know they were even a
world record i know rob furlon was the
guy the canadian guy i didn't know there
was one you know and so i just cracked
over the rest of the tour
ended up getting shot in my helmet end
up getting blown up
you know and it was quite a horrific
tour my last tour was
and
and then [ __ ] the fan when i came
home
when you when you
successfully engaged that target and you
kill those two guys you know you've just
saved all the people that now can
extract that must feel good
yeah yeah but
it's funny you don't rejoice or you
haven't got time
to rejoice
because you're thinking ahead
of your next task your next mission
things like that
i mean moving on through that
were there any points in your career
that you
thought this is it
i'm gonna get killed in action yeah yeah
there's um
[Music]
they're two of them really two of them
now i've had the taliban walk in front
of me probably
15 meters and i've been on the ground
and it just walked straight in front of
me me and my number two
you know you're thinking [ __ ] i was
close
but i remember being in the building
once and the special forces lads sas
were doing an op
now
nowadays they've got a thing called fsg
which is one power and they do all their
sort of like um
covering support and stuff like that so
you haven't got to worry about that but
before that was set up they used to ask
from the regiment have you got any
snipers and you've got your lads we can
borrow because they're busy on the
ground and they wanted two snipers and
it was me and my number two that went
out and we went to this building and
this building was like a building that
jack built it was a multi-story building
had
six floors and it looked like a monk
story car park and it was made out of
breeze blocks
and we went to the top floor and we had
eyes on the
op going in where the sas did a snatch
and grab of a high profile target and
there was a mosque
about um 50 yards down from where they
snatched this guy and we had to stay
there two hours after they've done the
job
so they snatched them they went and next
week our car bomb went off outside the
mosque and they were coming out from
prayer and it shook this building and
then we could hear a noise
and we thought what the [ __ ] that
noise and um our cover had been blown
and the only way into this building was
a spiral staircase in the middle
and the insurgents were clearing it in
floor by floor and we're on the top
floor
and we said we need to go we need to go
now
and
that's the only time i've ever threw a
flashbang and it's like a grenade and it
bangs six times and it disorientates you
and i remember going down the spiral
staircase
had my wife fall out and
the spiral staircase was really small
like going down a castle one and the
only i could only have my pistol out
because my rifle was too large to do
anything so i was going down to each
floor checking it and we got to the
third floor and luckily they were right
in the corner away from the spiral
staircase and i just lobbed this stone
grenade anyway
stunned them and we went down to the
bottom
and a vehicle reversed in a tank a
warrior reversed in the back doors
opened and we all piled in the back
and that was it the vehicle just stayed
there and when i [ __ ] drive drive
drive the vehicle just stayed there and
we're like
i'm chugging on the commander's leg but
we need to [ __ ] go now and it turned
out the driver had been hit in the head
through a gap this big because he put
the hatch down
and um yeah he's
the back of his head was gone and i was
trying to hold it in
um it was all over the commander's legs
their brains and god knows what and i
was trying to
hold it in but he was gone
um so we had to wait for another vehicle
to come behind us to push us all the way
into a safe location
yeah that was a bit touchy
there's a
another one where
i um
where i
was in this place called the p-jock in
iraq
and this p-jock only had um
18 people in
and um it was me and my number two was
sniper in there and from
probably 11 o'clock at night to five in
the morning gates of hell
gates of hell would open and they'll try
to overrun this this facility and the
reason why they tried to overrun it is
because there was a prison we were
trying to protect and that hope rifled
targets in and they were trying to get
them out you know and um it got to the
point where
it
when i was in the sniper hides looking
taking targets out and we were getting
shot at everything
and it got to the point where i thought
[ __ ] we're gonna go over run here
you know and i said to my number two and
i said we're gonna we're gonna struggle
here we're gonna struggle we're running
low on ammo running on sniper rounds
everything
and down
the ladder was a um
a paradigm phone and it was red
and it's where you just dial in a number
on a little card you get issued and it
gives you credits and you ring up home
and in the lull of the fight
i climbed down this ladder and my phone
turned you up
i just wanted to hear a voice
and um
i said okay upset i said to her i said
i love you
and she goes um
yeah i know you do what's wrong because
what's all that noise
and i said
something going on i said but i love you
so much you know that don't you
and she goes yeah i know you do
that's cause i'll phone you in the
morning promise you i phone you in the
morning
[Music]
and um
[Music]
i um
put the phone down and we cracked on
and um we made it to a morning
and i phoned her back
and i didn't tell her what was going on
um
i just said so it was going off i just
wanted to tell you that i loved you
that's all
yeah it's um
it's hard to listen to stuff like that i
don't feel a little bit you know
emotional yourself um something that's
always
seemed apparent to all of the crew
whenever you've come in because each
time you've come in and we've met you uh
tanya's come too yeah and you two seem
to have such an amazing bond together
and you know a lot of your stories
she's my life support yeah
it was my um
it was my dog
who's who passed away you know a few
months ago or betsy
um
who saved me from suicide
and tanya
um
yeah a fantastic woman
can ask
anything anything you know and she's
always been there even when i'm in a
wacko afghan i mean they're [ __ ] [ __ ]
she's always been there
you know always been there
we've met you before and um in the
previous videos we've made we talked
about betsy and then she actually
featured in one of the videos a lot of
the comments we had on those videos
went back to your relationship with her
it was very sad to hear when you came in
today that she passed away do you mind
telling the story of how she saved you
we lived in america
uh for three years
um
them two guys that i killed you know in
afghan were two high profile taliban
leaders
and um i started getting death threats
so they knew who you were they knew
because my information got leaked to the
media when i came back to england
and my wife's name my daughter's name
everything even my dog's name where i
lived everything so we had to we got an
opportunity to go to america to live
and um
we moved out there
and tanya went back to england
uh to see her family and i remember
having a
h k eckland clock 45
pistol
and
it was
on the dining room table
and where the dining room was was the
the sofa
and
i'd unload it
and i'd
practice putting the eye put in my head
i put it in my mouth so i gagged
just getting [ __ ] angry
you know and then [ __ ] hitting my
head and everything going on
and i couldn't i couldn't take it
anymore
you know everything
so i put run rounded and i cocked it
and um i put it in my mouth
and i just [ __ ] held it there
and i was pulling back on the trigger
and betsy was on the back of the sofa
and she um
she looked at me
she trained me high
and she turned her head
and um
i looked at her and i
sort of eased off the trigger and i put
the gun down
and i reached out to somebody
um a friend of mine who lives in texas
and he was concerned
and the police came round to my house
and they knew about my story and
everything they knew who i was because
the guy from texas said look him up he's
all over the internet this is this guy
he needs your help
they took the gun away
and they wanted to take me with them you
know for my own safety but i said i'm
fine i'm fine i finally
convinced him that i was fine
yeah she saved my life
she saved my life
and um
just the bond we had you know was just
second to none
second to none
we've skipped
a little bit there because we've gone
from you being extremely successful in
your career yeah
to obviously in a very very
dark and bleak place to try you know to
think about something like that
was that something that happened quickly
or was that something that was a gradual
build up
over a period of time when i was in
afghan
i
hit a 30 kilo anti-tank mine
and it blew me out the wagon my driver
his legs were shattered everything and
the vehicle was just demolished
and something clicked in my head
it was like all the tools that i've been
on
everything that i've seen
everything that i've done
this wall it just [ __ ] shattered
and i couldn't control my emotions it
was just like
coming at me and i'm just trying to
trying to fight him you know and
i managed to subside them feelings
and
when i got blown up i broke my arms um i
got a brain injury and my hips were
knackered
you know my hand
and
i still couldn't control these feelings
and remember
going off that i remember um going into
the um
into the chinook helicopter wrapped in
tinfoil that's the last thing i remember
and i remember waking up
and all i could see was white
and all i could see was like a
psychedelic going past people in white
white
and i thought i'm [ __ ] dead
that's why i felt i'm [ __ ] dead here
i'm dead
i'm
[ __ ] now i grabbed this one person i
reached out and grabbed them
and everything's white and i can't focus
everything's blurred and i grabbed this
one person and i said um
can you tell my wife that i'm sorry
just tell her that i love her
somehow get the message to her
that i love her and i'm sorry
and um
they gave me an injection to counteract
the this painkiller
and um i was in hospital and the person
i grabbed was a doctor
so i wasn't in heaven at all you know i
wasn't dying
but i still couldn't control what was
going on in my mind
they put me in plaster for
six weeks because i broke my arms
the plaster was taken off they made me
do 10 press-ups and it sent me back out
to afghan
oh god i didn't know that yeah
they sent me out and that's where i went
on to pandas ridge
and
i was taking raw painkillers
um
sort of addicted to painkillers because
i was getting migraines a hell of a lot
i couldn't focus
um
i felt
a lot of guilt a lot of anger
and i just couldn't control
and when i came off that tour
um
tanya noticed it first
she noticed it first that there was
something different there was something
different about me you know um
and i'm quite open for my sex life
through
being on my own want to be on my own all
the time total isolation my anger
everything that not eating properly not
training not doing anything just felt
worthless you know
and then the army noticed it
and when the army noticed it i got
called in
and um i didn't 23 years it took half an
hour to get kicked out
half an hour
no thank you no goodbye no well done or
anything
goodbye
it's gone that's it you see it you just
what is it an assessment or what happens
you sit a med board right and the only
reason that med board is is to see what
money you get when you come out
right it's not to go [ __ ] me this
bloke's [ __ ] well [ __ ] up so you go
in there knowing they're going to let
you go yeah and they're just going to
assess how much you should get paid to
leave right yeah and you you're gone
any support network afterwards no not at
all i pay out my own pocket for my
support
so you left after that time
with a lot of physical damage
a lot of mental damage and you're just
back home yeah
sitting there
walking and they sound sounds bizarre
but you rock you just
trying to focus and you're rocking
yourself and
they just fill your medication
make you a zombie
you know it took
a good couple of years
for me to find that equilibrium
of medication
to give me that happiness
to feel
a bit normality in my life
and
[Music]
and to find that
i fought the lost spark between me and
tanya but if you spoke to tanya's
because
i never lost it never lost it it's all
in your mind and she says it's sometimes
now on my bad days
you know it's in your mind you're okay
you're here
you know you you said you grew up with a
sheltered life yeah and you went through
a sheltered life into quite a mature
life yeah prize fighting then the
military then you're out in the military
did you think you knew what mental
health was do you think you knew what
ptsd was no
because often a lot of the people that
we talk to when they've gone through
that sort of upbringing
you know it's it's nobody's fault but
often they think it's something that
happens to weak people or something that
happens to people that don't understand
you know don't understand what it takes
to be what they are
was that something you had to accept the
fact that you might be suffering from
mental health was it was there a shame
in there as well
um
[Music]
a failure to
accept it
if there's nothing wrong with me
nothing wrong with me come off a meds
there's nothing wrong with me or any
medication for and then you [ __ ]
crash
and then you become somebody you're not
you know and then you become to the dark
place and then you start thinking of
suicide and stuff like that
and um
[Music]
yeah it's it's
and then you have to accept it you have
to accept that you've got mental health
issues and sometimes i feel ashamed
because
some people throw mental health around
and there's nothing wrong with them
you know and other people have got
severe mental health and they deserve
all the help they get you know and
sometimes i feel ashamed to have mental
health i think a lot of people still
think it happens to people who aren't
properly set up for things or things
like that and we had we did another
piece with a veteran who explained it
really well as he said like because he
he had complex ptsd and he basically
described it as like i got physical
injuries there
and this is a mental injury i got there
and people just didn't get that it was
the same deal yeah
do you do you run into that ever people
that just sort of aren't really equipped
to
process it or understand it do you think
these days is there a bit more
understanding around it no one
understands
i got an instagram and from lad's bible
and me doing other podcasts and my
following is massive
and um i answer i try to answer every
single
person
that writes to me comments wise did you
get a lot off the back of the lesson
massively really and it's people
reaching out to me
you know saying yeah i do this i suffer
from misogyny and it's me giving them
support going look this is how i coped
with it and this is how i deal with
things like that you know and they're
saying oh thank you thank you for that
you know and
tanya's reach reaching out to tanya as
well like the wives and girlfriends
saying how do you cope my boyfriend does
this things like this how do you cope
with and tanya's reached out to them as
well you know because i think it's
it's not understood and it took me a
long time to realize that you got
military ptsd
and civilian ptsd right and
[Music]
is there a difference
and i don't think there is because ptsd
is ptsd
you know so you got
fred down the road he's been knocked
over by a car
and it's horrific and he's nearly died
now he's got ptsd we've got me who's
done 10 tours seen horrific things done
horrific things and
i've got ptsd
it's the same thing
but doctors don't know how to cope with
military ptsd i've not got a [ __ ]
clue and i've witnessed to it when i've
gone to the doctor
and all i've done is gone like that
printed a bit of paper off go to our nhs
veterans mental health do you think all
right
so you go there and they they don't know
what to do
you know they give you
five five sittings sessions
and that's that that's you've gone
after them five seconds and you're going
well i still feel the same where do i go
from here
you know or you can reapply in a couple
of months time i might be hanging from a
tree then
you know so there is a massive
failure
in pt people with ptsd especially with
veterans or ambulance drivers fire
brigades police officers there's a
massive
supposed the thing there that you've
described as well which is which feels
unfair is that the police the veterans
the fire fire officers they've basically
done that job to help other people serve
their country and it's as a direct
result that they might have had some
problems or difficulties and the fact
that there isn't a kind of safety net or
support network when they come out seems
quite unfair
do you feel
what's your feeling towards the army now
bitter
um angry
the way that they do things
um but i'm one person the army is a
massive thing
you know and i always
it's funny i always give the same
the information my granddad gave me when
i was a child
and if anyone says i want to join the
army i say join the engineers
join the engineers get trade
become a bricklayer carpenter surveyor
anything you become you can become
airborne you can go for special forces
as an engineer you can do this you can
do that he goes but leave the army with
something you can fall back on
and that's the only information i can
give anyone who's wishing to join the
army you know is get a trade don't think
of yourself as a grunt on the ground and
you want to join the infantry
get yourself a trade you had a lot of
incredible experiences and you had some
experiences that have caused you a lot
of difficulties and challenges
if you could go back and do it again
would you take the same path now i went
for sf
um training and i got a really bad
injury in my knee and i didn't finish
selection
and
and then i'm married got married and
then i found out in hereford there's
like a 95 divorce rate and things like
that right and it's not what i wanted no
you know because they're under demand
everything so i've sort of like
scratched it off but if i was in the
right frame of mind that's where i would
have gone and that's my biggest regret
it's not following that
special forces there's special forces
you're not following that and hat off to
people that have done sf training and
stuff like that you know and do you
think it would have been a different
outcome
yeah it would have been yeah i think so
interesting and it's it's interesting
because last time we met you you hadn't
lost your finger no so these injuries
are still yeah back and that was caused
by the explosion
explosion yeah yeah and they suddenly
just cut my finger off
and um i spoke to you earlier i've got a
hip replacement now on my right hip and
i'm just waiting to get the left one
done as well due to this how
how long after the explosion did they
remove your finger oh it took ages yes
yes yes this this was done
it's just done last year right it took
my finger off because no one was willing
to do it i had to go to a veteran
surgeon and that was complications that
were caused by the explosion so how long
long's that like five years ten five
years five years afterwards
wow so it's still causing all these
ongoing you have to fight for it you
have to fight for it he's not the fact
that you can go to the gp and go i've
got issues
you know it's like i hit my place and
i'm 47 years old no one's going to touch
me with a hip replacement so i'm young
you know i had to go to a special doctor
you said yeah i'd take your case on
x-rays everything you went [ __ ] out
you need new hips right you're someone
that got hit with a lot of challenges
but you have turned them into a positive
and i wanted to touch on at the end here
about your survival school because i
remember when we did the last video we
it was something you were thinking of
yeah i think we actually did a
fundraiser for you you did you sort of
kick-started yeah which was amazing
because that was something that that was
just
viewers
feeling so sort of inspired by your
story that they wanted to donate
something and can you talk us through
your survival school yeah i've got
access
that i um let
52 acres of woodland down where i live
and
opened the bushcraft school survival
school to teach bushcraft
and
i
i do a lot for mental health
now you could be having the worst day of
your life
and just to get away in the woods and
totally relax
and
breathe a bit and talk to somebody that
experience mental health themselves
it's been
phenomenal phenomenal and i haven't
stopped this year i haven't stopped this
year and it's thanks the lad bible that
kicked it off
you know with the fundraiser that i've
managed to get all my bits and bobs you
know and um
trying to um
still get bits and bobs you know but the
school year is going from strength to
strength you know um trying to look for
a sponsor at the moment so i can um
offer instead of people paying
the sponsor could help me out so i could
offer free spaces to import mental
health issues amazing and say look come
on down this is why and i've done many a
time where i've just gone i've you know
i've done the school for um a whole
month and then three four weekends i've
not been paid myself at all i've just
told people to come down for free
because i want people to
feel relaxed and is that anyone that
feels like that yeah civilian military
anything anything i've had people i've
had alcoholics
i've had people with personality
schizophrenia i've had veterans i've got
severe ptsd and the response i've had
after they finished the school
you know um is you've changed my life
around creek and i remember one guy woke
up and he said it's the first time in
three years that i've woken up without a
hangover jesus that must make you feel
amazing yeah it does yeah and you think
to yourself [ __ ] out and he went to
bed again and he woke up the next
morning he goes that's two nights now
quake
amazing
it's such a lovely thing to hear and i
guess the final thing that i would ask
is
if there's anyone watching this
who is feeling
as you did after leaving the military is
starting to feel that they're not right
or people around them are saying to them
that they're not right or you know
something's different in a negative way
what would be your message to them talk
everyone says it on a talk talk to your
parents
talk to
your brother your sister talk to your
best friend
all right and i'm offering that out now
if you really are struggling reach out
on my instagram
and talk to me i'll talk to you i don't
care if it's like four o'clock two
o'clock in the morning i'm always there
to talk to on the edge of the phone
and if you are struggling totally and
you want to get away come to the school
listen craig it's the third time you've
seen it um it's always a pleasure and i
mean for us too every single time we
meet you it's just you just
overwhelmingly inspirational individual
i know that the crew all think that um
we did 100th episode
q a recently and your episode was picked
out by a lot of the crew as one that's
their favorite one that had an impact on
them
yeah
and uh thanks so much for your time
again
no worries
cheers
[Music]
so that was an interview with craig
harrison i'm joined here by josh who
directed that episode uh how do you
think it went yeah it's special powerful
um you know it's an incredible story
it's incredible and story of resilience
also kind of that political side of it
of just
how
to be honest like the uk army treat its
veterans and kind of how much needs to
be done and how little is done and
um it kind of has everything in terms of
the physical mental endurance of being a
sniper a great deal of which i had never
heard
um what it what goes into making it and
then his story his personal story
uh what he's gone through what he's come
through and kind of there's this sort of
at least some element of peace and
safety with where he's at now
um but yeah really powerful um
could listen to him all day very
articulate
um couldn't have enjoyed it more really
yeah i mean it's the third video we've
done with him um it's actually the
fourth video but the third one where
he's come in and we've met him and um
each time he's
there's something about when he talks
where he'll be talking
normally incredibly well and sort of
very vividly describing something and
then there's the odd story he tells
where it affects him and his face just
changes and when someone you're looking
at
starts to cry essentially it's really
hard not to have that response yourself
especially with someone like him that's
just a massive tough looking guy
seeing the things that affect him be his
wife and his relationship with this
little lovely sweet dog
there is something about it that makes
you feel like you're about to go as well
he's incredibly gentle
he is which is like he is an archetypal
looking
army sniper so i think that adds so much
and i think he just actually is actually
who he is um
danny you did the first one yeah i did
in the first couple of times craig um an
amazing man but it's like you end up
after doing these you follow a few of
the people on instagram so other people
you've like kind of and every time you
see one from craig and he's doing well
or he's doing after speaking or
something it's a really nice feeling
because just like it's good to see him
he does have good days too
and like we might see stories here where
he's crying and sad and stuff but it's
like
he actually had there's a lot to him it
was really nice actually he spoke at
length in this video about um the impact
doing the original video had on him and
the the the money that kickstarted the
survival school and all that kind of
thing and that was actually like
a really nice thing to hear yeah there
was a positive impact from doing it what
was your biggest takeaway from the
episode
i think um
i think how badly we treat our veterans
to be honest i think everything that
they give and you i kind of hear it
across the across the board with
with the army um it feels like you're a
gun for hire literally
while you're a young man and then you go
through a lot and like the way he was um
was in that bomb attack did 10 press up
sent back like it's get out as soon as
you can
and then there's no aftercare there's no
let's let's think about their purpose in
society what they can do after being in
the army
um so in terms of that that probably was
my biggest takeaway
i always think after every video because
he talks about it in every video but i
just always think his relationship with
his wife is so nice
special because like they always come in
together every time and um
it just seems like they're a really good
team like they've had some really
difficult times and the fact that
they're still really strong
we went out to speak to them you and i
after we'd shot and he came out of the
bathroom and he walked up to next to him
they just sort of like automatically
held hands
yeah and it's just like
it's just really nice to see that was
yeah
i thought it was interesting i didn't
realize when he said that people have
reached out to him on his instagram but
they've also reached out to her like the
wives of peop of people who've served
other partners who are having similar
problems have reached out to her for
advice and that was also a nice thing to
hear for anyone watching that's been
affected by any of the things that were
discussed in this episode there'll be
links in the description below
i looked up and i could see two guys
with a pkm
belt fed
russian machine gun
and they were hammering down on the lads
my rifle only shoots 1500 meters
so i had to
i called it lobbing
i lobbed the bullet in